so Manoj were you from urgently where'd
you grow up I live a little bit around
England downy and south-central and you
grew up with tell me what your family
and I grew up with a a piece of mother
and I had two sisters in the house no
dad no dad
where was that um I kind of not sure if
my mom knew who my dad was because he
never been in my life he he just gave up
it just seemed like they just had me
didn't they just went their separate
ways and how was your childhood it was
very it was very hurtful because my mom
she's to be me and she beat a lot
sisters and I tried my hardest to try to
stop her from hitting my sister and when
she is my sister
I went to do it all for my first time
when I was saying how do you get a lot
of education and I was hurt in a pervy a
group house I didn't like you know I ran
away from the group owes it is for the
group pose from the group house I went
to the streets and you're not ready to
him what age and you started working the
streets I start working the streets at
12:12 so your mom just let you run away
in June
well I wanted to stay at the house but
it was getting too difficult she had an
abusive boyfriend and his name was
Walter and when he lived with us in
Downey Downey was the best school for me
it was a good area but he found guns in
the house and he would beat on my mom
constantly constantly really had to stop
her from getting beat Oh
bronze is double yeah they hit the
middle of rooms we have to get him off
for her Italy I think Gotti Vicki so he
had to move out the house indeed from
the house who moved from Downey we moved
to South Central and that's where
everything went bad switch schools I
always give it up for education because
after the abusive boyfriend she had
another boyfriend come live with us it
was like she would let a lot of
strangers live with us a lot of strange
Brenda I didn't know my sister's didn't
know and who that would be our dad
living with us so 12 years old you go
out in the street and who were you
sleeping at night were you staying
well I ran into this one pimp may read
in he took me to
his body beach house and shoes it was
really different cuz she's way older and
she was a Caucasian lady and she was
older she had a nice house and stuff so
I'll stay with them and he started
having sex with me in the house again
she put me out and 12 years old I mean
you're picking up how many guys how many
guys at night well I was making more my
new I am now because I was younger and I
wasn't fully developed and that's what
they wanted a young face a young body
and the more I tell them my my real age
I said a lying about it I would get more
money so if you told them you were
actually 12 years old yes I like time I
was 11 going on 12 or 12 years old
did you ever get arrested for it is yes
our camp generous it constantly I mean
any night of the juvenile system I was
in caps gutter I was in las páginas I
was in central I was in still more I was
in all kind of group homes Penny Lane
and every st. Ann's I got pregnant at 15
years old so yeah yeah how many children
I have two kids maple by pimps and are
they with you
no my mom took them and I bet he could
see them now and it seemed and she told
him about me being a prostitute and it
hurts me it hurts me very back and she's
heard my kids against me and I don't get
to see them till you're exhaust your
kids well she she only came around when
I just did five years in prison and the
five years in prison I didn't get to see
them and when I got out my mom had heard
from where as I was getting into Social
Security money and she only was after
trying to be my penny for the money so
she started letting me see the kids I
only seen the kids three times since
I've been now and I've been out since
June
what do you wish your kids what do you
wish you could tells you your kids I
wish I could tell my daughter because
like she's growing up too fast and she's
living like my mom is raising her to
kind of the same way she raised me and
my sons who she's raising him the same
way she raised me like she yells at him
she beats them she she talked bad about
their she tells she tells them and they
keep on doing what they doing day that
she gonna put him in a system and she
don't want them and it hurts me it is
like she my daughter's she took girl
like she dances like stripper already
she talks back and stuff and she it's
just too much
how old is she she's seven and she knows
about me being in the lifestyle she
knows that her mom's a prostitute yeah
how many nights a week do you go out
well I don't work on Wednesday Wednesday
Thursdays and Tuesdays and usually like
the week is but I have to work um all
week and when on the Vice days Tuesday
Wednesdays and Thursdays I just goes to
the truck stop
where's the truck stop it's in
Victorville so you go out there and
truckers give you business yes what do
you do with the trucker yet well I like
it with the truck drivers because they
would gave me an easy 500 if I get three
of them doing it would be good amount
and the truck I just can't go on a road
with them like I tell them they can't
take me out of freeway because it was
try to probably take me to a different
country different state so I do buy
everything with them and they gave me
500 all right I tell you Mike all right
I'm doing bad because I am doing bad
and it will give me extra eye when I
come to LA they look Western Union money
and the guys that you end up doing
business with they're they're generally
cool or do you have problems yeah I have
problems that's why I just got a prison
because I got in a car with a guy I was
standing on Western in the 50s and the
guy he he kept going around in the car
and all other girls are dedo so he just
kept coming here asking me and asking me
I didn't think twice of it because I was
under the influence I was on crystal
meth
and this tradition with this trick
basically some people consider John's
but some people consider tricks he kept
my zooming down Western and he was as
bad and his app I saw and no other no
other females are dating him and I kind
of felt kind of like a and I was and I
wanted to rest my feet cuz I've been
enough for two days and I was on crystal
meth
so I wanted to make a quick money
because I already made about seven
hundred and then when when he picked me
up when he picked me up and he he told
me to give him head and I gave him head
and he said and he put it on the
Nightbeat he said you didn't do it right
give me all the money you made tonight
and getting my money back so I said I'm
not giving you nothing and then so I end
up snatching his bike and I stab him
with the knife his knife
and then I had to kick my heels towards
his window and stuff and then I have to
let myself on his car
and then when I but when I was getting
out the car he snatched my purse then he
took my purse to the police station and
it had my ID and the police came and
arrested me they said and when I went to
court they told me I didn't call the
police and he didn't happen in his car
so I'm a suspect and he called the
police and I didn't
it's terrible and and you got what
happened with the temp said he got threw
out of the cars
well I when I was well I think I was
about belly like 17 or something like
that I was with this pimp since I was
fifteen I had got pregnant by him and he
made me lose the baby because I told him
I want to be with him no more
I told him I wanna be with him no more
when I was like 15 I tell my I wanna be
with you know when I had the the
miscarriage but when I was 14 then after
that miscarriage and I turned 50 and I
told him I no longer wanna be here in
the world I don't I don't want to do
prostitution award and then that's when
he took me to this game called bps in
the jungles and some some females it's a
man's they attack me and and then when
they attack me I had to go to the
hospital and when I went to the hospital
they didn't know who to contact so they
contacted my mom and my mom didn't know
who I was because my face was bruised
very badly I got a permanent scar right
here from the car accident right here
and this part is a scar and it was um
open and I was scared to go when I went
to the hospital they told me that was
gonna put staples in my face right here
where the hole was and I didn't want
staples so I knew that a wound could
close on his own this because the skin
will close on his own so I ended up
healing the open wound on my oh and I
put peroxide it didn't start closing on
its own pretty good yeah and it was very
scary mommy for me because by my face
Mary gonna look the same it is like it
is like I put the pivot gel I went to
pip in jail and they already told you
three years
it ain't got all three years for all
they did sandy if it every time I seen
him he's saying he got killed news
nothing he always tried to like do stuff
to me and but he just got caught his
name Scooby he just got caught for doing
the same thing to another girl now you
got ten years went away
Scooby hit me with the car is because I
guess his pimp partners told him that I
was out and a pimp partner is like pimps
that get together and they act like
they're friends and and they just see
who can get the most girls and stuff and
they compete with each other and so one
of his pimp partners told him that he's
seen me and told him that baby you told
him that a girl died snitched on you or
whatever I see her she's on thing and
this and that and I believed I was like
probably in the 80s or 90s I'm not sure
and then I was walking with my heels on
and the middle of the street I was
trying to cross because he kept getting
on a curve he kept trying to like hop up
clown me so I tried to run across the
street and in here he got back in his
car and then he hit me he hit me with
his car you got real thighs he hit me
with the car and then when he hit me
with the car I went in the air did not
spread my hands right here my hands and
I scraped my face like that like I flew
in an air and came back down it's great
myself
that's a rough times yeah I had some
rough time it's because I've started
young I had a lot of hips because I
believed that I didn't have a dad figure
I didn't have a man figure I to get
enough attention so I was looking for
that in the streets but since I was so
young I felt like I had it harder to do
to most people because I was only 12
years old so when when I tell these guys
I don't want to be with them no longer I
don't see where the money's going are
like the situation just gave that I got
be tired they don't let me eat it all
let me sleep they make me walk for days
and I didn't have no home to go so that
I couldn't go to my mom house I couldn't
go to Auntie house I couldn't go to the
granny house so once I tell the pimps I
don't want to be with them no more today
they far away to try to mess up my looks
at most and most of the parents would
tell me oh she she's not gonna look the
same
she ain't gonna let the same she leave
me I'm a mess her up I'm a destroyer
what so what the relationship with the
pimp is what they they keep all your
money well sometimes I had the ones that
let me keep money this started when I
started doing crystal when I started
doing crystal they allowed me to keep
the money cuz I'll be up for like two
days three days making money and I'll
have to keep taking mines and lines and
lines and then they'll let me keep money
that they would say is allowing
to be fair because I want to keep like
200 a looking like 500 and as I starting
it older the money was it the same any
good so do you use drugs yes which drug
do you
I didn't crystal meth in when I was in
prison is that the crystal meth was
expensive so I tried black before heroin
yes buddy and I'm shooting you smoked it
yeah what are you using today um I
didn't look crystal meth how much school
did he get I only went to the since
grade but through our elementary school
I was ditching school because I couldn't
concentrate because I didn't know what
man would be in the house when I go back
and I was looking for a way out maybe
with my mother I didn't know like what
will go on if I will get hit and all
that stuff and I and I was embarrassed
at school because I didn't have with
other kids had a school I didn't have
material stuff like about yeah like nice
shoes
I don't have nice clothes on yeah like a
week we live in LA
oh yeah like a week go clothes to wear
for a week if it you're doing it right
now I would have to like where to say
pants in Swiss shirts are cool it like a
different I'll see
do you think what do you think would
have changed your life as a kid I do
wish I wouldn't say to this system and
with this fool like I wish I would just
stay in a foster home and everything
attached to my ball you've never thought
about my sister well peas and just
thought about myself because my sisters
they died I heard like I hear they like
they live better life that I didn't
right now but one of my sisters in
prison but she's still like my my
favorite but it's like my mom just told
me like a couple of days ago that she
wished she'd never had
just like must get you down sometimes
yeah it gives me down but usually we're
not do drugs and I'll make my own money
like now I like renegade and I don't
like having over him but I can't work
the streets too much because pimps head
over the streets and I'm on parole so I
meet guys here in here and all I have to
make money like that but the prices is
not the same from when I was young when
I was younger when I when I was a
teenager older you know 27 a 27 they've
been doing this is 12 yes
well darlin thank you so much for
talking to me good luck with their
vision and getting your kids back
or were you saying right now last
they're on the side of the freeway in
the end I made like a will carboy I went
around and with like some I've made like
a little area where I sleep by the
freeway
so you're basically homeless yeah how
long you been looking like that
I'm sick I got a prison since June she's
truther
and people come come in a tent and a
knock on my tent they tap on a tent and
in May and then when I don't ask her
they just unzip it and they come and
rape me in it I had to go to the doctor
several times what advice would you give
a young girl who's thinking this might
be the career choice right well there's
a lot of good programs out there I've
been working with children of the night
to try to help me I don't know if you
guys know about that program but
children of the night it's a good
program Casas a good program and there's
people out there fighting so girls don't
have to be pimped out girls I'll have to
use their body and if a man love you he
would he wanted it from you then he
wouldn't put you out there and the best
advice I'd give to a woman is get
married and make sure that that person
loves you never put their hands on you
and to watch how they dress and stuff
because a lot of perverts out there
they're like little girls
I'm an Irish thank you so much for
talking to me and good luck with
everything okay